le diable fois c'est l'histoire de
nageuse tourmenté qui participe à sa
dernière course aux jeux olympiques
sessenheim school optionnel de paix est
maintenue mais juste des pieds nadia est
personnifié par une vraie nageuse
katerine savard médaillé de bronze au
relais 4 x 200 m aux jeux de rio aux
côtés derrière mainville une autre d'un
jeu se délite kate une saveur face de la
piscine olympique au plateau de tournage
j avais aucune idée en quoi je
m'embarquais noms proposés que de postes
que demandait d'avoir peur de pas à
répondre aux attentes de pascal
couchepin
[Musique]
pascale plante c'est un ancien nageur de
niveau national devenu réalisateur à son
deuxième film il a voulu poser en
confiant les rôles principaux à deux
jeunes athlètes de le faire avec des
vrais athlètes tu as fais en sorte qu'on
n'avait pas besoin d'un trucage non
seulement on n'a pas besoin de trucage
mais ont même que toutes ces salles de
sport sont filmés en cinq ans
alors ouais sportifs ont vraiment mis
dans la rampe société des lits des
initiales du film c'était bourse est une
saveur insiste ce film n'est pas
autobiographique il expose des
tiraillements intérieurs d'une jeune
athlète
poussé vers la retraite le comédien
pierre yves cardinal avait remarqué
l'intensité du jeu des deux recrues sont
venues de la scène était encore en
larmes de gfa troqué et s'ils sont
vraiment là dedans le sont ils y vont à
fond là on a fait le film but à la fin
comme la main de vivre une telle
expérience avec ses meilleurs amis
le film a été tourné en partie à tokyo
environ six mois avant le report des
jeux à l'été 2000 21
d'ailleurs rien et catherine s'entraîne
toujours à vue de retourner au japon
cette fois ci dans le rouge l'athlète
olympique
là c'était
monde savait
mais à votre sort en salles le 18
septembre après une sélection officielle
au festival de cannes 2020 les deux amis
ont confiance de faire bonne impression
validé jean françois poirier
radio-canada membres